to one of your more epic projects I mean
they're all Epic but truckla yeah you
cutting into a Tesla and turning into an
epic truck what was that like where did
the idea come from the idea came from
that I really wanted an electric pickup
truck like I'm only really driven
electric because I got my driver's
license pretty late and I'm like one of
the first generation drivers it's like
probably never gonna have a gas vehicle
um but yeah this was in 2018 as well
2018 was a big year yeah yeah uh or
2019. I can't remember and I
figured that we could just make our own
so you took a Tesla Tesla Model three
model three mm-hmm
and you cut off a piece of it
and you turn it into a pickup truck
what's the um
uh it looks pretty badass so like what
what are some of the challenges of doing
that it's unlike other projects you've
done yeah it's very much outside of my
realm like I'm not a car person I
haven't worked on cars before so we
brought in a big team
um and had another project manager for
it and stuff because also like cars you
definitely don't want things to go wrong
like there's no part of me that wants to
[__] around and make something that's
going to be really unsafe for me or for
other people who are driving with me
um
so yeah I mean it was about a year of
planning
and then we got the car and then we
spent a month just tearing it apart and
trying to make it I was so set like I
really wanted the car just for its
function and
I was like I'm so fine with it if it's
really ugly but then we managed to make
it actually look really good oh so that
wasn't part of the discussion like how
the final thing looks I was I wasn't so
I wasn't that fussed about it I was like
I just wanted to I just want it for its
function like I really want this car I
don't want it because it looks cool but
then it ended up looking pretty cool as
well and I'm really
I mean even now a couple of years later
when there are some more options of
electric pickup trucks I still stand
truck law
like she's like rivian Ford F-150 like
they're all great but they're giant
you're sitting there on the porch in
your in your
cowboy hat
yeah drinking whiskey and saying with my
Cattle Dog yeah yeah
shotgun I wanted like a small 90s pickup
truck